a pesar de La tregua pactada en Sudán
continúan los enfrentamientos entre el
ejército y el grupo paramilitar fuerza
de acción rápida Far además de aviones
caza sobrevolando la capital artumo el
conflicto entró en su tercera semana y
deja cientos de Muertos
estuve trabajando en Sudán Durante los
últimos 13 años y debido a la situación
de violencia e inseguridad aquí debido a
esta guerra deje todo mi casa mi auto
todo y todos mis ahorros durante 13 años
Me voy de aquí en realidad
entre tanto se vive en escenas caóticas
en todo el país entre quienes buscan
huir y aquellos que han decidido
quedarse los enfrentamientos empezaron
el pasado 15 de abril y se reporta
escasez de alimentos medicamentos y
combustibles
en medio del peligro para sus
funcionarios el comité Internacional de
la Cruz Roja llegó al país con un
cargamento de ocho toneladas de ayuda
humanitaria nadie ha logrado llevar
asistencia médica al país que es muy
necesaria
se espera que esta asistencia médica
viaje con bastante rapidez desde el
puerto de Sudán se entrega los
hospitales que más lo necesitan y que de
hecho requiere un alto al fuego que debe
ser respetado por ambas partes para que
podamos con nuestros colegas de la media
luna roja sudanesa entregar estos
artículos lo más rápido posible a los
hospitales por su parte la unicef
advirtió que más de 60.000 niños se
encuentran en riesgo de desnutrición
aguda en medio de los combates entre las
dos partes en su búsqueda por obtener El
poder del país